über zwei monate dauert der russische
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine jetzt
schon und ein ende ist nicht in sicht
auch heute wieder kampfhandlungen die
russische armee verstärkt weiter ihre
angriffe im osten der ukraine das ganze
lassen wir uns jetzt einordnen von
claudia major sicherheits und
verteidigungsexperten der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik stehen guten
tag guten morgen wie beurteilen sie den
momentanen kriegsverlauf den wir sehen
im osten der ukraine momentan sehen ist
relativ wenig bewegung also russland
versucht anzugreifen kann aber trotz
sehr starker bemühungen nicht so richtig
vorwärts kommen die ukraine versucht
gegenzuhalten kann kleine gewinne machen
beispielsweise eintracht gibt aber große
mode muss man sagen es bewegt sich nicht
sehr viel es gibt die sorge dass das
nochmal verstärkt russische angriff und
blicke auf den neunten mai gibt wo die
siegesparaden moskau stattfinden aber
momentan ist relativ wenig bewegung drin
dass die ukraine sage ich mal
gegenhalten kann liegt ja auch an
waffenlieferungen letzte woche hat sich
deutschland entschieden doch schwere
waffen zu liefern den gepard abwehr
panzer inwieweit ist das ein schritt
richtung eskalationen es wurde ja so
auch angesprochen das ist eine gefahr
eines dritten weltkrieges geben könnte
also die eskalation geht ja ganz
eindeutig von russland aus diesen
angriffs und vernichtungskrieg führt
deswegen halte ich den begriff
eskalation nicht für falsch man kann er
sagen dass deutschland damit auch das
macht was viele die verbündeten der
verbündeten in eu und nato machen die
usa die von auch schwere waffen und
frankreich auch großbritannien auch die
östlichen nato staaten auch das heißt es
ist eher dass deutschland da sich im
großen im guten guter umgebung mit den
partnern befindet was die eskalation an
geht es gibt ja auch immer der den
hinweis auf die nukleare eskalation in
auch russland macht muss man das glaube
ich ganz klar sagen dass
natürlich jeder krieg jeder konflikt an
der anatom markt beteiligt ist ein
großes risiko hat man muss aber auch
überlegen was man damit erreichen will
und sie wollen einmal eine weitere
unterstützung abhalten der westlichen
staaten sie wollen aber auch und das ist
ganz wichtig unruhe und angst in den
westlichen öffentlichkeiten schüren also
es geht darum dass wir die
öffentlichkeit druck auf unsere
regierungen ausüben und sagen macht man
nicht so viel für die ukraine weil sonst
könnte es eine gefahr werden und diesen
mechanismus muss man verstehen und wenn
ich darf und muss man sich glaube ich
auch vor augen führen wie man diese
nuklearen drohungen ein oder muss also
wie dramatisch die sind und da sieht man
dass russland zwar droht aber die
drohung relativiert also der präsident
roth und der außenminister relativiert
wieder als einheit als einen raketentest
war letzte woche hat russland die usa
vorher informiert um missverständnisse
zu vermeiden also die drogen sind auch
sehr wieder relativiert worden sie sind
militärisch nicht untermauert die banken
sind nicht scharf gestellt wurden sind
nicht verlegt worden und die kosten für
russland wären enorm hoch weil auch die
usa gesagt haben sie würden ihre rolle
überdenken für china und indien wäre das
auch ein zivilisationsbruch das heißt es
ist natürlich ein grosses risiko aber
man muss es auch einordnen und sagen es
ist gewissermaßen wir müssen nicht mehr
muss das ernst nehmen aber nicht in
panik verfallen sprechen wir über ein
mögliches ende dieses krieges wobei ist
da muss man auch mal sagen große
unterschied zwischen waffenstillstand
wirklich dem frieden gibt es heißt oft
die ukraine müsse siegen aber wie groß
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit stammt jetzt
überhaupt dafür dass ein land quasi über
das andere sie es vielleicht früher war
ist was überhaupt noch möglich momentan
ist es sehr schwer vorstellbar dass
russland liegt also das ursprüngliche
sieg die ukraine zu kontrollieren das
ist aber auch schwer vorstellbar dass
die ukraine wirklich alle territorien
don bass und die landbrücke zugriff
zurückerobert dass es sehr schwer
vorstellbar das heißt die
herausforderung für die nächsten wochen
ist es zu sehen wie es weitergeht ob es
wirklich zu seiner zusammen verhaken
kommt uns zum stillstand ob die
kriegsziele re definiert werden von
beiden seiten dass ukraine sich mit
weniger zufrieden gibt oder russland
aber das wird die große frage der
nächsten wochen sein wie kann man da die
kriegst kreditlinien außenministerin
annalena baerbock hat jetzt einem
zeitungsinterview gesagt auf putins zu
sagen können wir uns nie wieder
verlassen wie ordnen sie das eine was
bedeutet das eben auch für unser
verhältnis zur atommacht russland für
zeiten nach dem krieg ich teile diese
einschätzung und es gibt drei punkte
meines erachtens team wichtig sein
werden für die zukunft der ukraine das
ist wie souverän kann sie sein darf sie
selber entscheiden ob sie ihn oder
nato-mitglied wird in welchen grenzen
wird sie bestehen und die große frage
der sicherheitsgarantien welcher staat
wird in zukunft dafür sorgen dass
zusammen von russland eingehalten werden
und dass ein möglicher friedensvertrag
wirklich respektiert wird und das ist
eine enorm schwierige frage
einschätzungen von claudia mayor von der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik vielen
dank für ihre zeit heute keiner